you have an album that's coming out on
Friday special edition album coming out
on so you've been you've been doing more
or at least concentrating more on music
than acting not really lately because
yeah cuz I feel like I see you yeah
television constantly so I don't
understand how much I think I had a
couple people come up to me at some of
the earlier shows five or six years ago
and yeah oh my god sure you're not gonna
work as an actor anymore that's the love
of my life man it is I will want to do
that too the day I die
the thing that found so interesting
about music is not only am i a huge fan
of music and live music but for me with
songwriting it was just another way to
tell a story yeah and what I've loved
about acting is getting together with a
group of actors and a director and a
cinematographer and what's the best way
we can tell this story it's very similar
to get together with a band and a
producer like Jude Cole and what's the
best way to tell this story the big
difference for me is you know on my best
day I'm not Jack Bauer but that was a
character and a lot of people will know
me from that the songs that I write are
actually very personal songs and and so
that took a minute to get used to
because I'm very private yeah we're
trying to be and all of a sudden I find
myself in front of 500 strangers singing
a song of the first time I got my heart
broken right this is that but do they
know necessarily like that cuz I tell
them I write you know I make a point of
explaining kind of where I was that when
I wrote the song and what I was going
through and and once I leaned into that
the response that I had from an audience
was just really extraordinary yeah and I
think on a good night when you finish a
show
whatever preconceived notion you might
have had of the audience and whatever
preconceived notion they might have had
of you if by the end of the show
everybody's walking away realizing that
we've got a lot more in common than we
might have thought uh-huh that's a great
night and so but I would have to imagine
it's pretty therapeutic to write to like
kind of live this existence where you're
like no I have to keep everything
private you know they wanna put articles
out about me they just everything in my
life
I'll keep over here and I keep away from
everybody and when you can figure out a
way to kind of not break those walls
down let people into your life and
realize that oh this is actually a good
thing because people are going through
[ __ ] on their own as cathartic and I
would have to say these two albums that
I've made are the closest thing I have
to a journal but no the experience has
been amazing but having said that you
know I think we did 150 shows last year
but we also did designated survivor I
know that's thinking you have this like
right you have this series you know the
star of a series and we go back to
Europe and we'll two or thirty dates
there and then I'll start shooting a
film with Stephen Hopkins who I did the
original series of 24 with uh-huh I'm
very excited about that
so you just love working you love being
on the moon I have found for me the
downtime is when I get in trouble just
stay busy enough then stuff kind of goes
better for me and I love what I do I'm
you know I've always said this I'm the
luckiest person I know I've been able to
do what I love doing for a career and
99.9% of the population doesn't yeah and
so I I will never take that for granted
I'm grateful for those opportunities and
with regards to music I love the band
that I play with and again the
experiences that I've had with the
audience's that have been kind enough to
come out to our shows has just really
been extraordinary and moving for me is
there a control thing to where when you
are doing your music ultimately as much
as you're working with a band and you're
working with a producer you're
responsible for
it's your it's your stuff whereas in a
movie a TV series you're responsible for
the acting but that's a more of a piece
of the puzzle we have it I mean both of
our team sports uh-huh they really are
yeah you know I certainly don't have the
musical knowledge of someone like Jude
Cole who produced both of the records
and I certainly don't have the playing
skills or the singing skills that he has
you know so I rely very heavily on other
people and and and but you're absolutely
right I am responsible for the finished
product and I have to either say yes I
this fairly represents what I wanted to
accomplish right but I have to say I
felt the same way about designated
survivor and and 24 and both shows I was
producers on so you know one of the
lucky things for me as my career has
evolved over the years I've been given a
little more room to have some input into
what that final product is and and
that's something that I've been grateful
for because in that circumstance look if
everybody hates it you can still stand
there and go well I'm sorry that
everybody hates it but I I I liked it
for these reasons and these are this is
why I made those choices right whereas
in early days you know you kind of are
left up to the wind you know to see
which way it blows and and hopefully you
know between the editors and the
directors in the studio that you all had
a shared vision for it have you ever had
the experience where you're like okay I
know I did a good job acting the scripts
look looks good I think this is gonna be
great and then you go and see it and
it's a stinker I you know I I've had
that experience more than once and it
wasn't that I thought oh my acting was
great or anything like that but you put
together a great cast yeah this script
is great because it attracted all of
these great people you've got a great
director in the studio is behind you and
for whatever reason it just doesn't work
it doesn't work and that's a chemistry
thing if we could all figure out how to
to handle that or manage that or put
that kind of in a bottle you know it
would be easy every film you would ever
make would be nothing right but it is
it's an amazing
to see when it works and trying to
figure out why like 24 I don't think any
of us expected certainly when we started
that it would ascend to the kind of show
that it became having said that there
are other projects too that we just
dumbfounded about why they didn't work
right what's most important I think as
as an actor as an artist is to be honest
enough with yourself to be able to look
at something and go that did work or
that didn't work and learn from that
yeah are you good at when something
doesn't work whether it's your fault or
not specifically if it's not on you if
you just know like okay the pieces
everybody was doing their jobs two
pieces didn't come together this time
are you good at admitting that or you a
guy who like takes it on himself
I would think I'm quite pragmatic about
ya know understanding because if you
can't learn from something that wasn't
successful you're in real trouble right
and so I think the more honest you can
be about trying to understand the
reasons or variables that led to
something being unsuccessful or not
working I think that's absolutely
paramount yeah so one's progression in
what they do what was it like when when
24 did what 2014 and by that I mean
you'd already done iconic stuff like you
already had your boxes checked off where
you had your stuff that people will
remember you forever because of this
because of that people had their
favorites but then you start doing
something like 24 and this entire new
wave of people not only has you I mean
people still I'm sure see you on the
street and you call you Jack Bauer
yeah and it's and I have to tell you it
was one of the most exciting times
because I've gone through you know
careers longer than I care to mention
but you go through moments where you
know certainly when I was young stand by
me young guns lost boys Flatliners
a few good man I had a lot of films in a
row that were very successful and
because I was so young I just took for
granted okay this is going to be the
rest of your life and this is wonderful
how this works
right right
and then I got you know I got bit in the
ass by life and I had ten years where a
lot of films didn't work and so 24 kind
of pulled me out of that and after doing
a few things that I actually really
cared about that for whatever reason
didn't find the success one hopes for to
have 24 take off the way it did I was
finally in a position where I was not
going to take that for granted and so it
was really exciting and and the fans
that ended up appreciating that show
were really hardcore fans they went in
full full bow oh my god percent and it
was exciting every time you would go to
work in front of the camera you knew who
you were working for because you'd meet
people on the street and ya think about
them and like I remember at the
beginning of season two I got I shot a
bad guy in the office of my superior and
he was freaking out saying oh my god
what have you done what have you done
and I turn around and I say I need a
hacksaw I'm gonna cut his head off and I
knew this second we had that line in
that scene structured like that but that
the people that were enjoying the show
we're gonna enjoy that moment and so
those moments became a lot of fun - and
exciting to do how do you deal with like
expectations of success right because I
think you know coming from the family
that you do getting into acting you're
you know just kind of getting in and
making a living some people might see
that as success but based on your family
you might have these kind of grander
expectations in the same way for music
you know when you succeed as much as you
do in acting do you have these things in
your head where success is now defined
as this unattainable thing success has
to be defined by the enjoyment you get
from what you're doing it has to be you
can't you can't put a dollar amount on
it you can't try and rationalize five
hundred thousand people enjoyed this so
therefore it's a success and it's four
hundred and ninety nine thousand didn't
enjoy it therefore it's a failure
you try and quantify or qualify this by
numbers you're just gonna be let down
yeah
the truth is each
job and each experience has its
positives and negatives and one in life
has to try and figure out how to make it
more positive than negative
storytelling there is always going to be
challenges in the storytelling and I
don't care if you're just sitting around
with a bunch of friends in a bar or
you're making a film where you're
writing a song but if that's the root of
what you love doing is storytelling then
make it about that and don't try and put
number values on everything and that's
that took me a long time to learn yeah
you know so it's it's again it's a very
kind of selfish thought as I'm tickling
it now but if if you value success
versus failure and how you qualify that
based on your personal experience and
what you manage to learn and what you
manage to get from that whether it's
developing a new relationship with
another actor who you loved working with
or whether it's playing in a town that
you've never been to before and you
create a rapport with an audience all of
those things you write a song and then
all of a sudden by the time you finish
it for the record you're like man I
wasn't so sure about that song but boy
do I love it now those are the great
moments that you have yeah I mean if you
can get there I'm sure that can also
preserve your sanity because you are
kind of in control of that you know
you're not comparing yourself to other
people you're not at the whim of
somebody else's decision making yeah and
and and it has it's a double-edged sword
there's moments where you've got a song
and you're so excited about it and you
start to play it that sounds great and
then you start to record it and then for
whatever reason it just lays dead on the
track you know and it just doesn't have
the kind of life that you were hoping
for and then that song doesn't make the
record yeah so it's always peaks and
valleys and I think at some point in
your life you realize that that's what
it is and the sooner you accept it the
more fun you'll have our have been
speaking of doing things that he enjoys
our producer Travis who's in the room
right there I'll Travis come in so
Kiefer can see you he is he is the
biggest Kiefer Sutherland fan that is I
mean ever
yes I mean and it's been I've known him
for over 10 years I've never known a
period of time where he wasn't your is
absolute like favorite actor favored
everything I would say you come up in
conversation on a fairly regular basis
and for that I apologize but thank you
very much man am i lying Travis yeah I
mean you're a big big fan oh yeah the
biggest that's very kind I don't know I
I think the biggest thank you and he
Travis asked if he could write questions
he doesn't I mean he's a producer but
I'm not on the other that much so he's
not here that much but I told him that
of course if he's gonna have the chance
to talk to his hero well that's very
sweet why shouldn't he have the chance
right absolutely take hope I have the
answers yeah me too
well like I already said yeah I'm very
happy that you're here thank you and I
am fan numero uno that's cool was it
always your dream to be an actor
no from the time when I was a young kid
I wanted to be a veterinarian
till I was about eleven then my mom got
me a guitar when I was ten and I just
took that guitar with me everywhere and
I played in a couple high school bands
and so music was something I was leaning
towards and then I did a play because I
could play the violin
I was cast when I was 12 years old in a
very big play because that was about the
Lodz ghetto in in Poland and I had to
play a violin piece at the top of the
first act and then I played one of the
characters and then I played a violin at
the top of the second act and was one of
the characters till I was killed and
that was my first acting job and I was
doing it with I was the only kid in the
cast everybody else was an adult and it
was the first time in my life where
adults kind of treated me as an equal
and that was one of the most exciting
times especially for a twelve-year-old
and then I saw my mother do a
performance of Virginia Woolf and it was
the only thing that I had ever seen
either of my parents do because I grew
up with my mother and my father's films
were all restricted for 18 in Brussels I
couldn't watch those and so I I knew
is an incredibly successful actor I just
didn't see any of the work until I was
much older but I saw my mother in a
production of Virginia Woolf she played
Martha and it somewhere between the
first and second actually stop being my
mother and I thought that was like the
coolest magic trick I'd ever seen yeah
that really piqued my interest so that
was that really around twelve thirteen
years old that's when acting became a
real interest to me
and I think certainly at that time I was
very aware of my father's success and my
mother's success and I didn't really
want to walk in those footsteps or
shadow but I fell in love with it in a
way that you know I just kept kind of
plotting on and and then both my parents
very graciously let me find my own way
they didn't try and manhandle you know
my young career and and so I made some
mistakes but I learned really quickly
from those and so it was it took a
little time you know you invent your
father in before he was in here oh yeah
and you know what he did that was very
very impressive without us we had no
idea to ask he just presented this
information and then proved that he
could fart on command yeah he said he's
one of the great I think flatulate errs
might have been a word that he used he
used to do it to embarrass the kids got
three younger brothers and a twin sister
and he used to do it in elevators the
worst part about him and the way he
would do it is cuz this guy's actually
taking time to work on it yeah so he can
throw a fart to do you can actually hurt
himself but make it sound like it came
from over there incredible and oh gosh
it used to make my sister cry and yeah
he's got a lot of other really great
talents as well that go beyond that have
you was that not a talent that you were
able to pick up on no it was a
desperately try to do that's too bad did
you have another question you'd
mentioned 24 earlier and I've been a fan
since way back when 24 was on and I
think that there's a little Jack Bauer
in all of us mm-hmm how much Jack Bauer
was really Kiefer
well I think like you said there was a
lot of want right gosh I wish I was just
gosh I wish I had this moral compass
gosh I wish I had his bravery gosh I
wish I could do all of these things you
know the things that I can tell you that
absolutely between me and Jack Bauer we
look the same
we run exactly the same speed all of the
physical stuff is there but what I
absolutely loved about the character was
that he was never going to win right it
was just you know and there are people
in our society that take on the jobs
that we don't want that are going to you
know more times than not fail and how do
you win when you're confronted with a
situation that you let ten people die to
save a hundred that's not winning yeah
there's no winning in that and so I had
such reverence and respect for that
character because of the sacrifices that
he was willing to put himself in for
based on what he thought his
responsibility was to his country to
people to innocent victims you know and
that doesn't mean he didn't make
mistakes and that you know that that's
part of that game but I really did feel
very strongly that this was a guy who
was going to try and do the what he
thought was the best thing right and
that at times it wasn't and he was gonna
and that created for a great
storytelling great drama yeah but no I
would have to say the character and I
are very different but there's aspects
of that character that I admire deeply
right you always hear about some of the
legends of Keith er Kiefer Sutherland on
the internet and whatnot and I need to
know if this one's true because it's
been one of my favorite stories for a
very very long time okay I'm an action
figure collector an adult an adult
action figure fan it's you know so many
years have passed now they don't think
I'll get in too much trouble for it but
they had they had made a an action
figure of Jack Bauer and they had sent
it to me for approval and and I was
doing a film with Michael Douglas at the
time in Toronto
so they sent it to me and I thought it
looked great and I said wow that's
actually pretty cool and so I phoned the
people back in Los Angeles and said yeah
no that's
you've got my approval and they were
like oh great okay and that was it
that's all they said okay and so me and
a friend of mine took it out drinking
and he took some really bad pictures of
the Jack Bauer doll in like a bottle of
whiskey and we got him into the frilly
drinks and then then we lit him on fire
doused them and I think we filmed that
[Laughter]
wax and clay and got a call the next day
I was like so glad you liked it so we
need you to send it back and I'm like
what and they said we need you to send
it back it's the prototype and I went
why didn't anybody tell me when you gave
me I mean it should have been the first
thing we need this for you approval and
then send it back immediately yeah it's
a prototype they didn't say anything so
it took a whole nother year it all to
come out because I didn't realize they
spent a whole year making it they did
create a brand new prototype and yes and
and whoever had to do the prototyping I
think was kind of pissed off because it
never looked as good as the first and
had I known yeah had I known I would
never have done it we just thought we
were being funny
of course it's the best part of the
story that it wasn't like you're being
like shitty or malicious it was just
like thought we were being funny and I
feel really bad about it and to the poor
artists in Japan who spent so long
trying to make that doll I am so sorry
well I'll tell you I think it's
hilarious Travis you have another
question do you keep in touch with any
of the old crew like Emilio Estevez or
Chuck Sheen that's certain I've I see
Emilio more than that I do Charlie and
then Charlie's just always busy
but and Emilio you know is writing and
making his films
that I regret kind of because that that
film Jung has won you know I don't get
into what film I had is a favorite film
but but it was absolutely undoubtedly
the most fun I've ever had making a film
and Emilio is one of the funniest guys
I've ever met and unfortunately so you
have this amazing kind of three or four
month experience with people and and you
feel like you're gonna be friends
forever but everybody's got families
they get other jobs it takes them out of
town and unfortunately people grow apart
but my memories of Lou Diamond Phillips
Emilio Estevez Charlie Sheen Dermot
Mulroney Casey Shaw Moscow is one of the
funniest guys on the planet we had the
time of our lives on that film and so we
don't get to spend as much time as
certainly I would like but when we do
see each other we tend to try and make
up for it do you want to wrap up with
one traveler one more question you were
talking earlier about films or projects
that don't work or you think they're
gonna work but they don't Dark City he's
one of my favorite movies what I'm
willing to how frustrating is that when
it doesn't land well I mean there's
there's a very simple explanation for
that
I mean Siskel and Ebert and I think Alex
Proyas deserve this they replaced
metropolis in their film school with
Dark City it was a 15 minute standing
ovation it can reviewed across the board
as really one of the most innovative
inventive its science fiction films of
its time New Line Cinema was owned by
Warner Brothers Warner Brothers had a
film coming out called matrix they were
too close in line with each other and
they had invested a huge amount of money
in that film and can Teresa sauce and
that's a great film it was one of those
unfortunate things that they were
completed around the same time they had
very similar looks in the timeless
aspect of that production
and one of others told newline you're
gonna take a back seat on this one you'd
eventually found its audience I'd and it
did and over time and I actually believe
certainly with the way technology has
changed in the last 20 years it is out
there for people to find and things like
that but at that moment it was you know
you think oh my god thank god I'm in
something that critics are liking and
people are liking this is gonna go
alright and then it's like eight
theaters eight theaters have not one in
New York perfect that's not good so you
know there's so many circumstances so
many factors that that lead to something
being successful and not successful that
are out of your hands I was very proud
to have worked with alex proyas rufus
sewell just such a fantastic cast and
and I was very proud of the film and at
the end of the day maybe at that point
in my life at the age of 29 I wasn't at
a place where that was enough right I
absolutely am now and I'm enjoying life
a lot more as a result of that one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the Sirius XM
app
[Music]